[Music]  we talked about you how are we following  up the valley I don't know no I am  writing music right now and have we're  just finishing up I think the first time  we're gonna put out I'm literally so  excited I love the new music I'm doing I  just want to make so I'm something  people happy it's all I want to do  [Music]  what's the vibe of the new songs you  know I think I'm kind of trying to do a  little bit everything right now so I'm  sorry I don't think I'm spreading myself  too thin but I think I'm exploring right  now so but the first one I hate just  admit straight down the middle good pop  song  we need just good you'll get pop we all  want in the end  [Music]